bonsoir Comme chaque jour du lundi au
vendredi il est l'heure du journal de la
rédaction voici les titres de ce mardi
28 avril 2015 50 ans en Yvelines à voter
son budget hier soir un budget marqué
par les économies en raison de la
diminution des dotations de l'État
l'ancien ministre député des Yvelines
Benoît Hamon par un de Keshav un lycéens
sans papier menacé à d'expulsion la
cérémonie organisée par Réseau éducation
sans frontières s'est déroulée à
l'Assemblée nationale et puis le rapport
du député socialiste et Guillaume Garo
sur le gaspillage alimentaire propose
d'interdire au supermarché de jeter les
produits quelques jours avant leur date
de péremption Pascal Rodier président du
Secours populaire des Yvelines nous
donnera son avis sur la question il est
l'invité de cette édition mais pour
débuter cette action ce mardi matin des
jeunes agriculteurs et d'Île-de-France
visant à dénoncer le manque de
traçabilité des produits de consommation
courante exemple sur la viande ou la
mention origine Europe ne permet pas
assez de précision pour les clients
Mickaël midoro et Mélanie OK
la traçabilité des produits alimentaires
et remis en cause par les Jeunes
Agriculteurs d'Île-de-France ouest
aujourd'hui ils sont venus coller des
stickers pour différencier les bonnes et
les mauvaises pratiques d'étiquetage
dans les supermarchés de
Fontenay-le-Fleury de Saint-Cyr-l'École
l'opération était baptisée viande de
nulle part là on a voulu faire une
action pour montrer aux consommateurs
et forcer les industriels et les
politiques à étiqueter leur produit en
mettant leur origine en fait le problème
c'est qu'on s'aperçoit que beaucoup de
donc là on a ciblé la viande puisque
c'est un mouvement national au niveau
des jeunes agriculteurs mais ça peut
être valable pour les autres produits en
fait sur la viande les biens
généralement
l'origine n'est pas n'est pas indiquée
cette action s'est déroulée devant les
yeux d'une dizaine de clients la plupart
soutiennent ce mouvement ça me confirme
dans le fait que je ne mange plus de
viande depuis déjà deux ans donc c'est
vrai que c'est plus j'ai pas forcément
confiance non plus
à l'origine c'est vrai que ces histoires
de viande chevaline à l'époque la viande
la vache folle de manière générale quand
on mange quoi que ce soit à partir du
moment où c'est préparé c'est pas nous
qui l'avons fait on sait pas exactement
ce qu'il peut y avoir dedans après à
partir du moment où c'est rentré dans la
circulation qui a pas eu de malade
vous mangez les responsables du magasin
ne comprennent pas cette opération coup
de poing nous vendons des produits qui
sont qui sont faits par l'industriel ces
astruciales restent avec la loi et nous
sommes contrôlés régulièrement par des
dpdation des départements
si vous voulez les fraudes qui viennent
contrôler le respect à la loi donc le
respect la loi s'il est fait nous ne
sommes tenues qu'à respecter la loi
cette opération viande de nulle part
devrait être reconduite prochainement
dans les supermarchés du département les
actions pourraient cette fois-ci
concerner les fruits et les légumes
il a donc fallu faire des choix arriver
à la tête de l'agglomération de 50 ans
en Yvelines l'année dernière la nouvelle
majorité de droite et du centre avait
lancé plusieurs audits afin de réaliser
rapidement des économies et avec la
chute des dotations de l'État le nouveau
budget voté lundi soir est marqué du
saut de la contrainte Catherine zulato
un budget volontariste et courageux
c'est ainsi que la présentée Armelle
aubryet lundi soir en conseil
communautaire malgré 5 millions d'euros
d'économies à faire pour l'agglomération
pas question d'augmenter la pression
fiscale de réduire les investissements à
hauteur de 48 millions d'euros ou encore
de supprimer l'accompagnement aux
communes de 38 millions d'euros via le
pacte financier par contre la majorité a
souhaité se recentrer sur ses
compétences prioritaires et revoir
certains postes comme les frais de
personnel en baisse de 350 000 euros les
adoss associations on a aussi fait des
efforts énormes dans nos frais de
fonctionnement notamment la masse
salariale on essaie d'être
vigilant là-dessus et chaque poste
vraiment est étudié avec beaucoup de
précautions on a aussi diminuer aussi
certaines opérations sportives
culturelles il faut que tout le monde
soit aujourd'hui traité de la même façon
le suivi de la vie
associative dépend déjà d'une une ville
d'une collectivité d'une commune et là
bien l'agglo pour faire plaisir à tout
le monde avait abondé aussi
sans critères bien bien évident donc là
nous aujourd'hui on veut on veut revoir
tout ça et on veut que chacun s'assume
l'action est mis aussi sur la
mutualisation de certains services en
ligne de mirent la Maison de la poésie
ou encore la maison l'environnement il
faut faire autant avec moi nous avons
fait réaliser des audits et ses audits
aussi nous ont prouvés que ce que nous
pensions était la bonne solution à
appliquer dans les prochaines années
donc aujourd'hui c'est pas de de
s'interroger si on continue ou non faire
de la poésie à Saint-Quentin la poésie à
toute sa place sauf que une maison de la
poésie ça fait peut-être beaucoup donc
aujourd'hui on préfère mutualiser à
travers le réseau des médiathèques que
nous avons sur notre territoire pareil
la même chose pour la Maison de
l'Environnement il faut revenir
aujourd'hui à des choses plus une baisse
de 400 000 euros pour le soutien aux
équipements culturels tous sont
concernés de la ferme du Mousseau
d'Élancourt à la Meurisse de Trappes
financer des équipements
communaux sur le budget de l'agglo dans
le cadre de la petite culturel ce départ
du ressort de la communauté
d'agglomération donc là on revient sur
ces participations le budget de
l'agglomération a été voté à la majorité
l'opposition c'est longuement exprimée
contre la baisse des aides aux salles de
spectacle les élus de la minorité ont
également regretté le mode de
fonctionnement et de ne pas avoir été
concertés dans les choix qui ont été
pris l'opposition a voté contre la
section de fonctionnement et c'est
abstenu pour la section d'investissement
à l'Assemblée nationale s'est déroulée à
lundi le parrainage de Keshav 19 ans
d'origine mauricienne et qui réside aux
clés sous bois depuis 2012 inscrit au
lycée Jean Perrin de Saint-Cyr-l'École
il est menacé d'expulsion en acceptant
de devenir son parrain par l'entremise
du Réseau éducation sans frontière
Benoît Hamon député socialiste des
Yvelines s'engagent à présent à défendre
le jeune homme et son dossier auprès des
services de la préfecture
il s'appelle Kesha Vila 19 ans ce lundi
dans cette salle de l'Assemblée
nationale ce jeune lycéen de
Saint-Cyr-l'École originaire de l'île
Maurice est un peu impressionnée Kesha
qui a rejoint sa famille maternelle aux
Clayes-sous-Bois il y a un peu plus d'un
an et demi a reçu le 7 février une
occupé une obligation de quitter le
territoire français applicable au 8 mars
alors qu'il est scolarisé en classe de
terminale bac pro commerce à 4 mois de
passer le bac il s'est donc qu'il peut
être emmené à tout moment dans un centre
de rétention RSF s'est mobilisé à
travers une pétition qui a recueilli 800
signatures et à travers donc l'indice
parrainage civil une action symbolique
sans valeur juridique mais qui permet à
kéchappe d'être soutenu par des élus de
la République Alexandrine Nancy
conseillère municipal au
Clayes-sous-Bois et Benoît Hamon ancien
ministre et actuel député des Yvelines
dans le texte de la circulaire qui avait
été passé comme Manuel Valls était
ministre de l'Intérieur il y avait la
recommandation faite au service de
l'État de prendre en compte situation de
ces jeunes scolarisés parfaitement
intégrés à la vie de leur territoire
c'est le cas pour que chef narraya et
j'ai accepté de le parrainer pour cette
raison là parce que je pense que il est
légitime qu'il puisse être
régularisé et avoir des obtenir les
papiers et qui me permettent de passer
son bac dans de bonnes conditions je
suis très ému c'est pas évident pour moi
je m'attendais pas à tout ça de venir en
France de passer d'autres têtes de
dissuasion comme ça j'essaie toujours de
garder le la foi courage et
j'essayef a déposé une demande de
recours gracieux auprès du Tribunal
Administratif un premier référé a été
rejeté l'urgence est de mise ce qui me
touche c'est que c'est un jeune qui
pouvait difficilement continuer ses
études
à l'île Maurice du fait de ces
conditions de vie familiale toute la
famille de sa mère était en France
plusieurs étaient français d'ailleurs
sur le plan humain ça me semblait être
une condition valable pour essayer de
l'aider à rester c'est la première fois
cette année que RESF organise un
parrainage civil le réseau s'occupe en
ce moment d'une trentaine de dossiers de
jeunes en cours de régularisation
l'invité de ce 28 avril Pascal Rodier
bonsoir vous êtes le président de
Secours populaire des Yvelines Guillaume
Garraud député de la Mayenne a reçu une
mission parlementaire du premier
ministre durant 6 mois il a travaillé
sur le gaspillage alimentaire un rapport
qui a été rendu le 14 avril on va en
parler justement avec vous un chiffre
tout d'abord 400 € par an pour une
famille de 4 personnes c'est le coup de
moyens du gaspillage alimentaire en
France la proposition qui a été faite
l'une des principales propositions c'est
de rendre obligatoire le don des
invendus alimentaires consommables à
toute association caricative habilité
qui en fait la demande ça signifie
également vos services est-ce une bonne
nouvelle vous allez nous le dire dans un
instant tout d'abord l'avis de quelques
cinq continents c'est notre question du
jour
je voudrais éviter de les jeter et
plutôt donner à ce qui ne peuvent pas
payer les aliments et par exemple au
pauvre bah c'est surtout eux qui qui
vont chercher dans les poubelles si il y
a des il y a des aliments qui ont été
jetés et mieux vaut leur donner quoi
parce que je pense que il y a pas mal de
gens aujourd'hui qui sont dans le besoin
et qui ont besoin de nourriture et faire
des collectes et permettre de donner aux
autres ce serait plutôt pas mal plutôt
que du jeter gaspiller comme si comme si
on n'avait pas besoin quoi classifier un
peu pour ceux qui ont besoin ça serait
plus juste bien sûr interdire je sais
pas mais restreindre vis-à-vis du
gaspillage et tout ça la surproduction
et
pour sensibiliser aussi les gens à mieux
consommer c'est important de pas tout
jeter et surtout avec les problèmes de
pollution qu'on a en ce moment et
d'environnement je pense que c'est
important de garder et de donner aux
autres obligatoires le don des invendus
alimentaires consommables à toute
association caritative habilité qui ont
fait la demande elle assume bonne
solution parce qu'elle redit pour le
Secours populaire
c'est une solution c'est à dire que en
fait ça va permettre de d'améliorer
l'ordinaire de ce que l'on est en
capacité de proposer aux personnes qui
viennent nous voir et en être plus en
plus pour obtenir une aide alimentaire
ça varie la palette des des produits
proposés puisque nous c'est plutôt des
produits qu'on collecte à la sortie des
grandes surfaces auprès de la population
en direct des denrées non périssables
donc et sinon les produits qui nous sont
donnés par l'Union européenne
en gestion le seul bémol si bémol il
peut y avoir par rapport à ce type de
décision c'est que en fait ça va
nécessiter pour l'ensemble des
associations qui seraient intéressés
pour pour travailler là-dessus à
investir fortement en termes de en
termes de matériel logistique parce que
derrière la redistribution il y a la
contrainte logistique qui est énorme en
fait c'est quelque chose qui se pratique
déjà récupéré les invendus sans qu'il y
ait cette obligation légale pour
l'instant en fait depuis
quatre ans au niveau de la Fédération
des Yvelines on a des structures qui se
sont mises à organiser la ramasse comme
on dit c'est venu très fortement dans
l'espace politique français à l'occasion
de la renégociation du Programme
européen d'aide au démuni puisque c'est
quelque chose de très répandu en
Allemagne une association partenaires du
Secours populaire en Allemagne qui
s'appelle l'étaffle en fait c'est une
structure en gros qui fait de la
réinsertion sociale et les personnes qui
sont en situation d'insertion vont
chercher dans les dans les supermarchés
comme ici et en contrepartie de leur
contrat d'insertion en fait ils sont
formés et
ça fonctionne comme ça ça fonctionne
dans le cadre de projets de réinsertion
là ici le sujet c'est de mobiliser des
forces bénévoles pour redistribuer des
produits qui sont tout de même en fin de
vie puisque c'est à deux trois jours
passés
en rupture de la chaîne du froid sans
risque sanitaire pour les personnes à
qui on va les reposer et puis il va y
avoir aussi pour les associations comme
nous la gestion des déchets si déchets
il en reste malgré tout puisque quand on
sait déjà par expérience que sur les
produits que l'on nous donne comme ça
quand un jour vous retrouvez avec trois
palettes de pain vous avez une peau de
bonne vous avez beau être de bonne
volonté avoir très faim et tout ça enfin
il faut les accuser les palettes de pain
et même en déclinant sous toutes les
formes ça peut être quand même compliqué
et pour nous se retrouver à la place des
grandes surfaces à avoir à faire le
choix de mettre dans les poubelles ça
peut aussi poser un problème d'ordre
moral et imaginer une personne qui va
aux portes d'une association
humanitaire comme le Secours populaire
et voir que des bénévoles jettent à
manger l'impact que potentiellement ça
peut avoir alors là je vous fais la
version c'est un peu un cadeau
empoisonné finalement cette décision
je le dis dans le c'est le problème du
systématique à partir du moment où c'est
systématique c'est que le tour possible
mais pas ceci dit il faut en faire la
demande ce sera pas une voilà il faut
mais en fait
les
vous savez comme moi je pense que dans
la grande distribution ils sont quand
même assez proactifs et donc là on a
déjà eu des appels de de grandes
enseignes pour nous demander sous 10
jours de leur donner les réponses pour
les 8 établissements dans lesquels il y
avait aucune association jusqu'à présent
qui venait chercher parce que les mêmes
endroits depuis des années nous disaient
non non et maintenant bah comme ça va
être obligatoire ils nous disent ouais
c'est super important de venir nous voir
et donc
la logistique en fait c'est même pas de
la mauvaise volonté c'est que en plus il
faut un maillage territorial qui
correspondent c'est à dire que si demain
je demande de bénévoles puisqu'il faut
être au moins ça pour pouvoir les
récupérer les produits de
Trappes d'aller à Ecquevilly par exemple
je prends un exemple exprès comme ça bon
voilà ça ça risque d'être un petit peu
compliqué et puis en termes de frais de
fonctionnement pour l'association ça va
ça va en générer quelques-uns mais pour
prendre un exemple qui est pas vraiment
sur ce territoire là mais qui est pas
très loin non plus sur Houilles il y a
un comité local tous les jours ils y
vont et ils redistribuent tous les jours
aux familles donc c'est vrai que c'est
mieux pour les personnes de pouvoir tous
les jours donc comme ça ça fait une
rotation entre les familles et puis il y
a une diversité de produits donc c'est
mieux en rendant obligatoire le don en
tout cas l'interdiction de jeter pour
les supermarchés c'est c'est denré c'est
d'en réalimentaire il faudrait un
accompagnement des associations comme
les vôtres des des aides ne serait-ce
que même financières pour gérer les
stocks des solutions qui soient
proposées il y a des équipements
logistiques incontournables enfin une
armoire frigo ça coûte au moins 2000
euros il y a 23 structures dans le
département
concrètement vous allez devoir investir
23 la structure dans le département deux
armoires frigorifiques à 2000 euros vous
comptez ça nous amène à plus de 40 000
euros quoi donc c'est début ça
représente des investissements pour nous
qui qui sont importants
et qui enfin il va falloir qu'on
réfléchisse donc après on a déjà sur le
département une dizaine de conventions
comme ça de récupération de produits et
partout où ça s'effet c'est parce que en
fait il y avait des équipes bénévoles
qui se sont donnés les moyens de le
faire et comme je le dis le fait de
rendre ça obligatoire au niveau des des
grandes surfaces présente le le risque
de mettre une pression assez forte sur
sur les associations qui ne sauront pas
forcément
toujours apte à faire face à l'ensemble
par exemple nous les structures sur la
vie nouvelle qui sont pas des petites
structures d'accueil des des personnes
en difficulté
au-delà du magasin de moyenne surface on
rentre dans des volumes qui sont qui
sont énormes en fait si vous si vous
saviez ce qu'un hypermarché jette tous
les jours en produits frais bon voilà
c'est
quoi pour la Secours populaire votre
activité bah ça pour les bénévoles dans
les structures locales ça représente
bien 50% de l'activité à l'année c'est
une vraie activité
qui demande des bras de l'énergie et
c'est pour ça que de manière un petit
peu têtu et insistante à chaque fois on
fait des appels à bénévole sur ces
sujets là parce que c'est c'est très
exigeant en termes de temps et donc là
si vous les si vous rajoutez une
contrainte qui va être aussi de pouvoir
avoir gérer le truc avant 10h pour que
ce qu'ils ont un métier aussi les les
gars dans les supermarchés et donc
il faut qu'ils sortent de leur stock
tout ça il faut pas que ça perturbe trop
non plus l'organisation de l'entreprise
donc on sait ce sera forcément on
connaît périence on connaît d'expérience
que c'est tout de même un petit peu
contraignant pour tout le monde
maintenant une fois que c'est organisé
puis que ça prend son rythme de
croisière
à la fin ça fait quelque chose de bien
quoi très bien on va profiter de votre
présence également sur ce plateau juste
pour faire un point par rapport à
l'actualité notamment internationale
Secours populaire français qui se
mobilise suite au séisme meurtrier au
Népal vous êtes engagé également s'il y
a des dons s'il y a des bonnes volontés
qui se manifestent des dons surtout
en fait
si vous voulez comme nous on fonctionne
pas comme des urgentistes de la sécurité
civile ou les pompiers volontaires ou
les choses comme ça on fait pas partir
de gens du Secours populaire sur la
l'urgence l'urgence des six premiers
jours on est plutôt sur la posture et la
réhabilitation après sur la durée c'est
à dire que classiquement là vous voyez
sur Haïti par exemple depuis que la
dernière catastrophe en Haïti on
continue de boucler des projets ça se
traduit en général dans la première
année qui suit il y a des une première
solidarité nécessaire qui va être aidé à
la mise à l'abri la potabilisation les
soins les apporter les produits de
première nécessité qui sont souvent
achetés dans la sous-région en fait et
ce qui se passe là au niveau de
l'association c'est qu'on a débloqué 50
000 euros au niveau national pour
permettre en fait avec des réseaux de
partenaires puisque on est on a des
partenaires dans un petit peu tous les
pays du monde surtout dans ces dans ces
pays-là l'Inde le Népal le Tibet ça fait
des années que on a des associations
partenaires sur place donc moi j'ai pas
les détails de ce qui va se faire mais
j'imagine que ça va se passer comme ça
se passe à chaque fois ce sont nos
représentants locaux ou dans la
sous-région qui sont mandatés dans la
par l'association Secours populaire dans
un premier temps pour amener les
produits de première nécessité et puis
après faire des évaluations de projets
de réhabilitation la plupart du temps
l'équipement collectifs un château d'eau
une école un site collectif les
bienvenus
il y a juste pour conclure est-ce qu'il
y a aussi un message à faire passer un
appel encore à bénévole sur le terrain
pour des actions qui vont s'engager dans
les prochaines semaines
on est en montée en puissance de la
campagne vacance et donc on appelle des
familles d'accueil bénévoles qui
seraient intéressés par offrir deux à
trois semaines à des enfants de 6 à 11
ans de se manifester auprès de la
Fédération des Yvelines
et à ce moment-là des bénévoles
viendront les rencontrer pour proposer
de partager leurs vacances à un gamin
qu'on a pas et donc il faut
régulièrement comme ça se tenir informé
en visitant notre site Internet et vous
verrez qu'il y a très souvent des
collectes qui s'organisent des
initiatives demain on a encore des
baptêmes de BMX au Vélodrome national
qui ont lieu pour des enfants donc voilà
ça ne s'arrête jamais Secours populaire
slash 78
les renseignements merci Pascal Rodier
président du Secours populaire des
Yvelines Secours populaire et qui fait
que c'est 70 ans de solidarité populaire
la suite du journal avec samedi dernier
sur la place d'Armes de Versailles une
vingtaine de voitures de collection
elles étaient rassemblées à l'initiative
de l'association Raoul Follereau qui
lutte contre la lèpre l'ignorance
l'exclusion et la pauvreté les curieux
ont fait un tour dans ces voitures
d'exception pour la bonne cause Mélanie
pocket Yolaine Torres
passer quelques minutes dans une Alfa
Romeo 2000 de 1972 ou une Brissonneau et
lots de 1958 quelques minutes pour
échanger autour des véhicules contre un
don de 5 euros réponse à toutes les
interrogations effectivement des
visiteurs puisque j'ai la chance d'avoir
une voiture peu connue donc qui est un
manquement je suis sollicité sur ou
quand comment et là on passe de bons
moments si pour une bonne cause c'est
quand même une cause sérieuse et aussi
parce que j'adore les vieilles voitures
les propriétaires et pilotes sont venus
bénévolement à la demande de
l'association Raoul Follereau pour
récolter des fonds destinés aux enfants
orpailleurs de Nami Sigma au Burkina
Faso cet argent nous permettra d'aider
ses enfants qui travaillent dans des
conditions inhumaines sur la mine d'or
qui sont exploités qui qui sont
confrontés à des activités physiques
bien au-delà de leur capacité ça nous
permettra de d'aider ses enfants aller à
l'école
à
ça nous permettra de les protéger de les
nourrir la fondation créée en 1968 par
le journaliste écrivain français Raoul
Follereau lutte contre l'exclusion
causée par la maladie la pauvreté ou
l'ignorance elle soutient actuellement
351 projets dans 32 pays dont la France
ce jour-là l'association a récolté 700
euros
nous en avions déjà parlé dans ce
journal un nouvel atelier original était
proposé pendant à ses vacances scolaires
à la maison des parents dans la ville de
Trappes en atelier de 5 jours animés par
l'association pour la promotion de la
citoyenneté des enfants et des jeunes ça
vient de se terminer par une
reconstitution de procès en salle du
conseil municipal Sephora Namani
elodiemen
2 ans de prison pour honorer 18 mois
pour Jamal et un nom pour Silas elles
ont été les peines prononcées par le
juge rosenfe lors de la reconstitution
de procès vendredi en salle de conseil
municipal de Trappes il s'agissait de
siéger une affaire de drogue
cette fois
atelier organisé à l'initiative de la
maison des parents en partenariat avec
l'absège toute la semaine dernière
l'enjeu était d'inscrire par an et
enfants dans une démarche de réflexion
commune sur la justice et la citoyenneté
une mission réussie car même les parents
en ressortent mieux informés cet atelier
est un atelier à particulier j'ai été
surprise je ne m'attendais pas je
vraiment je ne connais la justice un
petit peu mais le fait d'être acteur
d'une certaine manière m'a fait encore
plus constater qu'il n'est pas facile de
de juger qu'il n'est pas facile
d'aborder les problèmes qui que la
justice rencontre au-delà de la
découverte du fonctionnement de la
justice c'est parfois la sévérité des
décisions rendues qui a pu surprendre on
apprend des vous a propos de la distille
les temps de prison les condamnations et
tout ça et c'était bien parce qu'après
la représentation aujourd'hui on se dit
comment ça va se passer en vrai je
pensais pas que c'était aussi sévère ben
finalement c'est sévère même sur un
quelqu'un qui a une raison de le faire
ben c'est sévère du coup ça m'a ouvert
les yeux à prendre c'est bien mais en
s'amusant c'est mieux ce que les enfants
n'ont pas oublié de faire un bilan
général très positif pour cet atelier le
premier bilan qu'on peut faire c'est que
les enfants qui étaient là les parents
ont beaucoup travaillé entre leur
attitude et leur réflexion le premier
jour et aujourd'hui ils ont été dans le
bain ils avaient bien ils ont été
toniques dynamiques intelligent ils ont
réfléchi ils ont rajouté aussi donc ça
prouve qu'ils ont été passionnés par la
démarche après tout c'était le but
c'était le but c'était qu'il réfléchit
sur la justice mais d'un côté qui ne
s'ennuie pas cette action de
sensibilisation à la citoyenneté menée
par la maison des parents se poursuivra
en mai avec les élèves du collège le
village
on va les remercier les uns les autres
merci les parents
et c'est ainsi que se referme cette
édition merci de l'avoir suivi je vous
retrouve demain à même heure excellente
soirée sur TVfil tout de suite le 7 8
société avec cette question ce soir le
numérique à l'école est-ce une
révolution vos réactions avec le hashtag
7 8 sociétés sur Twitter un mercredi